Hey, I have something delightful for you today
in the voice mail segment.
I have today, a caller that may be the most
endearing caller we've ever had.
It sounds like just a delightful, sweet older
lady who is leaving me a beautiful voicemail.
And there's just a perfect little touch to
this.
You can hear my show playing in the background.
She didn't pause the show to call in and leave
us this voicemail or if he's listening on
the radio, she didn't turn down her radio
tinkle.
I love this is my new favorite caller.
Hi, David.
I really love this show.
And I do not think traffic is gonna find this
way again.
I just can't even believe such ever that propaganda
is running a country.
And Conshohocken to me are you share it all
together.
And there's my show continuing to play in
the background.
I love that.
That is my new favorite caller.
I'm imagining that her name is Gladys.
And I don't know why I'm imagining that.
But we that that is just absolutely heartwarming.
The keeping the show playing in the background.
You couldn't do it any better if you were
to stage it.
It wouldn't sound any different, which maybe
it is actually staged.
And I fell for it, but I love it.
And that's that's my new favorite caller,
Gladys, or whatever your name is.
We absolutely love you here.
OK.
On the bonus show, we will be talking about
could corona virus accelerate automation of
jobs in the United States and around the world?
Number two, Denmark and Poland are not going
to bail out companies that are registered
in offshore tax havens.
Can you imagine the United States doing something
similar?
I can't.
We will discuss it.
And Facebook has announced announced they
will be taking down some but not all posts
that are promoting protests against stay at
home orders.
People on both sides are furious about this.
Some saying why would they take any posts
down?
Others saying they should be taking all of
the posts down.
Free speech is being discussed.
People misunderstanding the First Amendment,
of course, is a factor.
And we will discuss that on today's bonus
show.
How do you get access to the bonus show?
Simple, quick, easy.
Two ways.
Number one, get a membership.
Get a membership at join Packman dot com.
You will instantly get access to the bonus
show option to make a pledge on Patry on a
$5 a month or more.
That's Patry on dot com slash David Pakman
show.
That's the second way to get access to the
bonus show either way.
Producer Pat will join me.
We will discuss all of these stories and more.
I will see you then or otherwise tomorrow.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.